And this is going to be a convenient way of writing the state to
see what happens next.
A zero and A one are bits, and if we think about the top two qubits as being a two Qubit register,
we're thinking about A zero, which corresponds to the top Qubit as being the lesser significant bit, and A one which corresponds
to the lower control Qubit
as being the more significant bit.
After the first controlled
U operation is performed, we obtain this state.
The classical state corresponding to the top control Qubit is a zero, so the result of the phase kickback
can be expressed in this way. Then after the second and
third controlled U operations
are performed, we obtain this state.
The idea is the same as for the first one, except this time we're applying the control U operation twice.
So we multiply A one by two in
the exponent to reflect this.
And now we can simplify this expression by thinking about the bits
A one and A zero together as an integer between zero and
three using binary notation.
That is when we think
about the two bit string, A one A zero, as the binary
encoding of an integer,
what we get is two
times A one plus A zero.
And the understanding is
that when we write Cat X, we're talking about X written as a binary string of length
too using binary notation.
So now let's focus on
these two control qubits to figure out what we
can learn about theta from them at this point.
The remaining N qubits are
still in the same state psi that we were originally given, which is really a wonderful
thing about this approach
because like I said before, we can use that state again if we want to gain even more
information about theta.
But for now, let's just think about what we can learn from
these two control qubits.
To help us to figure out how to proceed, let's imagine that we're promised that theta is equal to Y over four
for some integer y between zero and three.
In general, theta may not
be one of these four values, but this is a natural case to consider.
We saw in the original single control Qubit version of the procedure that if we were promised that theta is either zero or one half
the circuit would reveal which one it was. And we also noticed that in the version where we applied the
controlled U operation twice,
we could perfectly discriminate the case that theta equals zero from the case that theta
equals one quarter.
So we might hope that with our new circuit we can discriminate these four cases.
In essence, what we're
doing is that we're using the notion of a promise problem
to make the problem easier, so that we can see how to proceed.
And that's not a bad idea, in general. If you have a problem and you
don't know how to solve it, try making it easier.
If you can solve the easier problem, the insight you gain might be helpful in solving the more general problem.
And if you can't solve the easier problem, you're probably not ready
for the more general problem.
So keep on making it easier
until you can solve it.
Anyway, getting back to our problem, let's define a two Qubit state for each of the possible values of Y.
In other words, phi Y is equal to the state
shown on the top of the screen when theta is chosen
specifically to be Y over four.
And here are those four
states written out explicitly.
So just to reiterate, if
theta is equal to Y over four for Y being zero, one, two, or
three and we run our circuit,
we're going to be left with
one of these four states, whichever one corresponds
to the right value of Y.
And we just wanna figure
out which one it is.
And the question is, is this possible?
And the answer to that question is yes, because these four states are orthogonal.
If you compute the inner product
between any pair of them, you'll get zero.
And because they're orthogonal, they can be perfectly discriminated by a projective measurement.
And in particular we can
express such a measurement by defining one projection for each vector like we have here.
This always works, anytime
we have an orthonormal basis, and you can check this
against the definitions we saw in lesson three
for this specific case
if you're so inclined. So we conclude that it is
possible to accomplish our task,
which is to learn the value of Y from the state that's shown
on the top of the screen.
And if we'd like to do that
with a quantum circuit, we can proceed as I'll now explain.
First we can define a unitary matrix V whose columns are the four
vectors listed in order.
That matrix will have the action described on the bottom of the screen,
on the standard basis states,
and we can write down the matrix
to see what it looks like.
Because V maps each standard basis state, kappa Y to the vector phi Y, we have that by applying V dagger,
or in other words V inverse to phi Y will transform back the other way to the corresponding standard basis state.